8を始めて言ってるし
赤瀬ございます
っとあの
実は結構長い事やっておりまして
を沸かし総勢いるので
あと木を記しておりますけど
ええ
案内さいって言う
ジャンルが最近ありまして
登録世紀の発見
役が席に暇限らないこういう施設でも
のきれずみたいな所でも人が集まるところは
空間情報だけでは割り切れないかという面
で
誤字情報や図形情報
も
支援道具に使って役とか
公共施設を貼りやすくしよう
そんなことを
じゃってきた
このあのつくばエクスプレスもまああの
あ邪魔からつくばまで
だいぶ前ですけど
この赤い駅名標というのは実はあまり
珍しい
つくばエクスプレスと合うんです
第二条番線っていいまして定盤線の空白地帯でそこを通そうということで
乙女2分はなんかどうか
うんこ待ってもらうと思う
鉄道が通ったんですね
で
でもよくよく建設間近会場間近になっていきますとどの条文戦のイメージを引きすると
お客さん薩摩藩ざっというわけで
二幹二条番線と違うイメージを作り上げ8日
いうようなテーマで
もちろん案内溶かせばが機能が落ちちゃいかん
そういうことでいろいろ工夫している中で赤い駅名標にしよう
みたいな事を考えて
やりましたまあおかげさまであのつくば駅作れそうですね
20年かけて黒字化しようという
結果だったんですけど
4年で黒字化しまして
皆様に大変ん
ご愛用いただいているという状況ですね
でまぁ私はこのうち入りましたのは1972年
なんですけどもこれを追ってますどうぞ表町
43年前何ですか
まあこういうふうには看板と呼ぶんです
いっぱい触ってますね
富士銀ツールとかだいぶアウトか
東西線のエヴァとか入り口とかまあ色々な子供がこう
あちこち
溢れかえっぐう館15時になる気
no 状況でした
東京の地下鉄マート京都試験の交通はの1955年にネットワーク化しようという
方針が決まりましたね
地下鉄どんどん係数すると乗り換え気もどんどん
それから総合着2の下部どんどん増やすというようなことがありまして
咽頭最初のまあ今東京オリンピックが近いと付いてますけれど東京戯曲の開かれました
1964年に
日比谷線ってのは開催しましたね
e 6 a 日東オープンする
銀ぞ線窓している日々ません
っていう純バッグたいです
日比谷線ができて銀座の駅が元々丸ノ内線は西銀座五気と血がはみんな性は銀座行き
だったの
つなぐ
日比谷線の便回切ってもできてもまあ遭遇車ということで痴漢でつないなんですね
alden ためにも当たらない
だけれども景色がなくなってし
だからどこがで失せだかどこがいい
乗り換え先だかよくわからんということが落ちてしまったんですね
そんなことで私は
あの
この3計画を
やることになりまして73年から2003年まで30年間
なんしか舌の
ええ
子守を
てきました
前の写真と比べていただくと思う
だいぶ整備前に進んだ道
ありますけど情報も開けるとか体系的に情報提供していこうとかそういう考え方が
そこで以前全然なくて
のベストが見える情報を必要とする所おいてきた人が必要とする情報
それからその何何はどっちだって示せばいい場
それから相関関係を伝えない限り
よく理解できないというジャ
こんなような
ものをまあ整理して
やってい
で
長く30年間
恋をしてみましたけれども
2004年にあの何時ヶ月が東京メトロに民営化しまして
その機会に私はま引退させてもらった
というような
そうです
で今日はですねああこういう中でわかってきたっていいますかね
意外と自分としては一生懸命やってきたし
4仲良くなったじゃないのと思い思いたいところですが
なんかどうも基本がわかってなくて
わかりにくい状況は目ではましませんか
というのが強く疑問に思ってました
特にマン大事な今日は4つのポイントに
絞ってお話を思いました
思いますけれども
こういう空間蔵のコミュニケーションの基本みたいなことを一同皆さん動い次第に考え
てみたいな
一つ目は見えますか見分けられますかって言うんです
el ってものを見分けるちょっと違うんですけど
ウェーブって何ゾーンまでちゃんと入ります勝手なん
見分けるっていうのは a と b がどう違うんですか
まあそういうようなことを
それが
ええまああの私が in パイしてだから年寄りの
何やてケチをつけるとも行かなく思いますが
ドンボーノ右展望はな
年配の方が一生懸命覚えていますねこれ地図も非常に小さくなりまして
盤面が小さくなってエリアが広がって
実は広告中耳になったもんですから
なんか広告だらけです非常に明確なってしまう
手前の黄色い
あのこれでやってもいいですかやっちゃいけないいいんですかん
この手前の黄色のうーんものもその
実はこのくらいの病だったんですね
町頭もこのくらいの大スターだったそれが
あの子ちゃんめちゃコレ実は民営があるときに広告にしたいということを言い出しつつ
話
その町の人たちに号哭をたどるが
どうもお金になるということで
郷家くん役の知り合いの企業に営業しちゃったんですねうちも出しても出してっていう
ことでいっぱいいっぱいになっちゃったもんだから
その
情報がよくわからない人ほど困ることになってし
それからはこちら側が最近の新しい
セレクションさえないなにわっちラってやつなんですけれども
まあかなり子はちょっと思うもしいろいろな純装備の上部になってしまう
例えばこうこれは三田線はあの
ファースペインと美味しくて
万能性は綿切ってほしいんですけど
まあいっぱいいっぱいでシャッターもながら同5
い分けられなくないと
何が何だか分からなくなってしまう
という言葉
ですから最近はその情報を多く増やそうという傾向が強すぎて
多くいっぱい入れるもんだろう子がどんどん小さくなってめちゃくちゃになってしまう
みんなが一緒になってわけわかんない
あって痩せませんかというのがいい
ですねかもう一つ
大事なのがその2話というようなのあります
見晴らしで後サインそのままじゃないんだけど
見晴らしがある見渡せるってことがわかりやすさを基本ですよということを
大松よく
例えばグってバーのニューヨークの
ブランド先負
溶液なんですけど
旺盛なホールです
左手はの jr の田植えじゃうの船は役は
ぽくて最近なんでも立派の役だったんですよ
ございます
んで r は結構売り場こっち
木の歳できープリはどこにあるその次の歳で憲兵が左がその次の最大の売りはこちら
半袖が入ったわけです
でキープ領土 versus 見えないわけですよ
こういうのは難しくないですか
入浴 g セントラヴィてみると号の文字プリパが見えちゃうんですっ
手前から
1方で全部見るどこがどうなってるかわかる
状況が分かるということがわかりやすさの重要な1つポイントする
ですから全体像がしっかりで打っ
これがまあ大豆なのに
こういうものを柱の陰に大事なものを柱の陰にこの中にきっぷりもあるんですけど
考えしてしまってさん一生懸命きゅっぷい過去チップルは来てても明瞭にスパッとか
なることにはならないんじゃない
ことを感じおお空振っこの3つ
インファーラー氏とかで次にいう見通しとかこれはサインだけの問題じゃなくて
いろいろ学問も含めてなんか物事は買うってのはそういうことなんだと思う
次見通せますかっ
見晴らしと見通しちょっと違う
見晴らしはもう全体見る日投射砲のパスて作っていう
これもその右の方は弁輪の白い
左は悪名な8
といいですね
技やさて歓迎したってして話題おりませんだ
全員が全員をとっているっていう
の駅ですけどまぁ何が見通しをワークしているかと言うとこの
ダメですよね
屋根をかけてしまってだから歴史的に
もちろんその1本の線が通って地面の上に
人生の飛びますね jr線とができてくる
なんだどんな増えてくる
んだけど昔ながらのや屋根をできるだけ壊さないで足し算他社の対3でやっていこう
全部一度クリアしてきれいに再生を作りまそういうことをしないで足し算たちのんで
行ってきたのだから
まぁこんなさがサインだらけおじ食べてる
出口だけで10万ですよ
露禅するだけで14
ものすごい数のものがありながら加えて見えないようにわざと蓋をしてしまっている
n 年みるとこの階段から上の限ってさらに上に行く
エスカレーター階段下も見えるからあっチップでうちかなーってこう
受けるんですよ
だから3統制されているに話せるこれは非常にわかるってことの重要なポイントじゃ
ないん
それからん
覚えやすいですか
もう一つ分かるという実は意味がわかっ
状況がわかるさっきの見通すの筋道がわかっ
この3つ目のこれは意味がわからん
この辺が分かると分かりやすいんですけれども
うん
この想い意味が分かることのすぐ隣に覚えやすいですかっていう話な
これはあの自分の家があっている
ありますけれども丸ノ内線のシンボルは赤い今るって
昔きれい
今やヤクザずになって
白い四角の中や考える会でそんな悩みて書いてある
いっぱい行こう
うん思うし情報になっていますけどこれ渋谷ですよね
dt 度が
z
新聞を与えています
et とか絶倒ってのは本当に役に立ってんだろう
渋谷もう頃東京の泥子線が地下化しまして非常にあの
ん
アクメを図る
このなりつつありますけれども
加えてですねこの
フィリ at とか
ey とか
不思議な希望を使ってお客さんを案内しようとしています
で
若一すぐに脱着個付いてるならいく
1部に連敗した場合パケだったんですよね
であのん
案内が全然無いからわからないくれ
が非常に多いんですよ
案内しかない案内だけなんですよ
東急東横線近いでも案外が全然ないっていうのはつまりその色やくるから
東急デパートがあるから今ならついてだろうおばあちゃん持っちゃうんですよ
etp 泥底から一転だけよイメージ
覚えられるっていうのはイメージ記憶なんですよね
覚えやすい覚えるというものを文字を保持のままで終わるんじゃなくても力発生して形
とか色とかなんか状況黒情景とかそういうものを一緒になって
イメージとして記憶する
マルマルってやつはグッ
お外とか
全員って思う人もいるかもしれないね
ワード
まるって言う形で人々はいろんなことをイメージできれますですからまあ加えてマール
の戦斧文字が湧き
我々よく見える変えたから
このマル路線こういう意味は分かりませんって人はまあいいなぁ
いなかったです30年間やって
そういうクレームはなかっ
これはつまりイメージしやすい
d ティーン日本人がー
鈴ちんといった何じゃう
のイメージといけないわけですよね
dt という
今から行ってもスペリングこの形ができます
イメージできない加えてこの渋谷の駅は
あの
dt と z 勝ち立つ
同じ一つ乗り場に行くらしいのですなぜか dt とで2つ
誰なんだろうと
もちろんられた人はあるいは若者だ
塩と視点とハンドボー線が総合値を積ん体してるからその名前だなって分かるんだけど
太めで外国の木となんかは相互直通でシステムなった
分かりませんから
こんな加えてあの吐く通りで取られちゃうわけなんで
ダブル病気とられるということになりますのでこういうその
c ブロの使い方っていうのがあの
わけわからん
まあそんなことでん
長いことやっていましたけれども
連続な方はかもろ例は
私は腹を立てておりまして
見えますかつにはがせますか伊藤伏せますか
覚えやすいですかこういうことを問いたい
思っております
時間になりました